it was another brutal week on wall
street with some stocks at their lowest
point in decades this is concerning for
anyone but especially for those who rely
on that investment money for their
retirement sasha loftis has more on what
experts and stockholders here in las
vegas are saying
ryan it's been a rough couple of weeks
for investors especially for those
invested in the stock market those i
spoke with today say this is forcing
them to take a step back and really wait
it out
we're afraid
but at the same time we have to have
hope it's a turbulent time for the stock
market throwing investors around the
world and here at home for a loop we're
staying still right now because we're
all standing back watching tim ledesma
is one of those stockholders and he says
weeks of consecutive losses really have
him concerned
friday brought more brutal news with the
dow in its longest weekly losing streak
since 1923
and the s p 500 falling 20 percent since
january the economy is a little bit
fragile right now brian gordon principal
at a plot analysis says now is a time to
be cautious as many cite inflation and
higher interest rates as driving factors
you may have some folks that were
on the verge of moving into retirement
just maybe a different deal now and they
may be rethinking that strategy and they
may keep working for those on the cusp
of retirement and needing that money
soon this is a much larger issue and for
those far from retirement the down
market might actually represent buying
opportunities for the most part it's
important to think about some of these
things on a long term basis and
ultimately we'd expect some level of
recovery going forward on that note the
stock market historically always
rebounds for example over the past 30
years the market is up 870 percent
it's something tim says he's ready for
we have to set ourselves up for progress
a lot of people have also been talking
about the possibility of a recession in
the coming months now brian gordon told
me the concern is there but it's too
early to tell exactly what will happen